- [Instructor] Let's say we have
a hypothetical reaction
where reactant A turns into products.
And let's say the reaction is second order
with respect to A.
If the reaction is second
order with respect to A,
then we can write the rate of the reaction
is equal to the rate constant
k times the concentration
of A to the second power
since this is a second order reaction.
We can also write that
the rate of the reaction
is equal to the negative of the change
in the concentration of A
over the change in time.
If we set these two
ways of writing the rate
of reaction equal to each other,
and use of calculus,
including the concept of integration,
we will arrive at the integrated rate law
for a second order reaction.
The integrated rate law
for a second order reaction
says that one over the concentration
of reactant A at some time t,
is equal to the rate
constant k times the time
plus one over the initial
concentration of A.
Notice how the integrated rate law
has the form of y is equal to mx plus b,
which is the equation for a straight line.
So if we graph one over
the concentration of A
on the y axis, and time on the x axis,
so let's go ahead and put that in here,
one over the concentration
of A on the y axis,
and time on the x axis, we
will get a straight line
and the slope of that line
is equal to the rate constant k.
So slope is equal to K and the y intercept
is equal to one over the
initial concentration of A.
So the point where our
line intersects the y axis
is equal to one over the
initial concentration of A.
Let's look at an example
of a second order reaction.
C5H6 is cyclopentadiene, and two molecules
of cyclopentadiene will
react with each other
to form dicyclopentadiene.
Our goal is to use the
data from this data table
to prove that this
reaction is second order.
However, we have to be careful
because in our balanced equation,
we have a two as a coefficient in front
of cyclopentadiene.
Going back to our hypothetical reaction
where reactant A turned into products,
there's also one as a
coefficient in front of the A.
And if there's a one as a
coefficient in front of the A,
we can use this form of
the integrated rate law
for a second order reaction.
However, for our problem, we have a two
as a coefficient in
front of cyclopentadiene.
And that means we need to have
a stoichiometric
coefficient of 1/2 in here,
and that changes the math.
Now when we set these two
rates of reactions equal
to each other, and we use
calculus and we integrate
to get our integrated rate law,
because of this one half,
we end up with a two in front of the K.
So thinking about y is equal to mx plus b,
now the slope of the
line is equal to two K.
So now for our reaction,
we can write our integrated rate law
as one over the concentration
of cyclopentadiene
at some time t, is
equal to two kt plus one
over the initial concentration
of cyclopentadiene.
So if we look at our data table,
we have time in seconds and
we have the concentration
of cyclopentadiene,
but we need to have one
over the concentration of cyclopentadiene
so we need a new column.
So we're going to calculate
one over the concentration
of cyclopentadiene.
So if the concentration of cyclopentadiene
when time is equal to zero
seconds is 0.0400 molar,
if we take one divided by 0.0400,
we would get 25.0.
To save some time I've gone ahead
and filled in the rest of this column.
Notice as time increases so
as we go from zero seconds
to 50 to 100 to 150 to 200,
the concentration of
cyclopentadiene decreases
because cyclopentadiene is
turning into dicyclopentadiene.
Next, we need to graph our data.
So we're gonna have one
over the concentration
of cyclopentadiene on the y axis
and time on the x axis.
Our first point, so when
time is equal to zero,
one over the concentration
of cyclopentadiene is 25.0.
So if we go down to our graph,
we can see that when
time is equal to zero,
our first point here is 25.0.
And plotting the other points
gives us a straight line.
Next, we need to find the
slope of this straight line.
And there are many ways to do that.
One way to do it is to
use a graphing calculator.
And when I used a graphing calculator
to find the slope of this line,
I found that the slope is equal to 0.1634.
Thinking about y is equal to mx plus b,
our slope should be equal to two k.
So to find the rate constant k,
we need to divide the slope by two,
which gives us 0.0817.
To find the units for
K, remember that slope
is equal to change in y over change in x,
and on our Y axis, our
units are one over molar,
and the x axis the units are seconds.
So therefore, we can
write the rate constant k
is equal to 0.0817.
It's to be one over
molar divided by seconds
which is the same thing as
one over molar times seconds.
It's important to point
out that most textbooks
don't cover how the two
as a coefficient changes
the integrated rate law.
And so a lot of textbooks will simply say
that the slope of the line
for the second order integrated rate law,
is equal to K.
So a lot of books would
just say the final answer
for the rate constant is 0.163.
So you'll see you'll see
a lot of textbooks say
that the rate constant would be 0.163,
one over molar times seconds.
However, since the coefficient
in front of cyclopentadiene is a two,
technically this rate
constant is the correct one.
Finally, since we got a straight line,
when we graphed one over the concentration
of cyclopentadiene versus time,
we know that this reaction
has second order kinetics.